[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لا ينظر الناس مشاهدينا الكرام
بكثير من الاهميه لوزاره الشؤون الاسلاميه
والاوقاف جمله الاهتمام عاده ينصب لما
يسمى الوزارات السياديه والمتمثله بالدفاع
والداخليه والخارجيه لكن من زاويه اخرى
تشكل هذه الوزاره والمهنيه بكافه الشؤون
الدينيه في بلد ما موقعا بالغ الاهميه من
عده نواحي مسائل الافتاء موقع الدين في
الدوله اداره الشؤون الدينيه والدعوه
تنظيم عمل دور العباده كلها مسائل بالغه
الاهميه خاصه في عالمنا العربي ومن هنا
كانت الاهميه لتولي ضيفنا في الحلقه
الماضيه وهذه الحلقه هذا المنصب واين في
بلد مثل الكويت تتعدد فيه التيارات
السياسيه الاسلاميه بين اكثر من مذهب وبين
المذاهب بنفسه نفسها الدكتور علي زميع ابن
الحركات الاسلاميه في مطلع شبابه وحتى
نهايه الثمانينات لكنه قرر الخروج من فكره
التنظيم الى عوالم ارحم وشكلت فتره توليه
الوزاره محطه في تجربتها الطويله ينتمي
الرجل لفكره التجديد بشكل عام ومنهمك في
عمليه التنظيم على اساس علمي ينطلق من
فكره الدوله للتيار او الحزن واراد لبلاده
ان تخوض غمار التجديد والتطوير وكانت
مسائل الافتاء والاوقاف والتنظيم العمل
الدعوي والخيري حقول الالغام التي سار
فيها خلال فتره اعمله اغضب التنظيم
والماسسه الكثير في بعض الامر لكن سرعانا
ما قبل به الجميع وتفاعل مع مشاريعه واصبح
لهذه المشاريع الرياده في الكويت والمنطقه
عموما في هذه الحلقه اكمل معه المسيره
الشخصيه والمهنيه في توليه وزاره الشؤون
الاسلاميه والاوقاف ثم وزاره التخطيط
والتنميه الاداريه واعرج على مسائل الوقف
وتنظيمها ورؤيته التقدميه لهذا العالم
وافاق تطوره وما يمكن ان يقدمه في حياه
المجتمعات الدكتور علي جميع المفكر
والسياسي الكويتي في المقابله الليله
فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
سعداء بوجودك في الحلقه الثانيه من
المقابله وكنا نتحدث عن المسيره التي
انتهت بالطلاق بينك وبين جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين احنا الصاحبين نحب العبارات
اصبحت علاقه علاقه مفكر
الجواب عليه انه هل الاخوان
شيء غريب
انا طبعا وجودي في الوزاره كوزير سنه 9
شهور بس ولكن بقائي التاريخي انت في وزاره
الاوقاف
انه انا خرجت والجميع في حاله على الاقل
ما اقول المحبه الاحترام المتبادل لان في
النهايه اكتشفه
لما تنظم عمل المسجد انت سنه العمل الخيري
وحصنتهم
لما تعيد تنظيم الافتاء تعطيه تحصين فهو
تحصين يخدمهم في النهايه لما تاتي
للعلاقات الخارجيه وهذه قصه كان في تخوف
لما تاتي الى موضوع الزكاه
واقرار قانون الزكاه لما تاتي الى قضايا
الافتاء وفي قضيه الاختلاط وازمه من
الستينات من نشاه جامعه الكويت 65 الى
اليوم وهي ازمه وتصدر فتوى مستقله تنزع
فتيل سياسي واجتماعي ثم تفشل هذه الحياه
اياهم جعلت الناس تستشعر انك على الاقل
تشعلي ان تكون ذو هدف موضوعي همم انتهت
العلاقه في 88 تقريبا الدكتوره ايضا صدرت
رساله الدكتوره هامه ولافته جدا هي همم
تاريخ الحركات الاسلاميه في الكويت وحينما
نقول حركات اسلاميه تتكلم عن الاخوان
المسلمين جماعه السلفيه الحركات الشيعيه
السلفيين كافه التيارات والتبليغ والتبليغ
الدعوه حزب الدعوه الجماعات الشيعيه
وقضيه مجموعه الشيخ الشيرازي اللي هو كافه
التيارات الاسلاميه
وارتباطها ايضا بالمجتمع وانت قدمت مقدم
مهمه عن المجتمع الكويتي وطبيعته وارتباط
هذه النشر لكن اريد ان اكمل الجزء المتعلق
بعملك الحكومي الذي انتهى همم يعني انتهى
لاحقا مع وزاره التخطيط لكن وزاره الاوقاف
توليتها بعد التحرير بعد التحرير الكويت ب
صحيح تتويجا لمسيرتك مع وزاره الاوقاف ما
الذي حدث حينما اصبح الدكتور على الجميع
وزير الاوقاف والشؤون الاسلاميه في الكويت
قال انه هذه الفتره كانت فتره مهمه
اختلافه ما ابرز ما تم فيه هذه الفتره
القصيره ايضا
قبل اصدرت الامانه العامه للاوقاف
كنت وكيل وزاره
لابد قبل ما ندخل في الوزاره الداخليه او
خارجيه
صحبه اسلاميه خارجيه
الثوره الايرانيه
ودخلت الثوره الايرانيه في بعدها الجديد
ليس البعد الاسلامي
نهضوي او لا هذه المره اصبحت السياسيه
المذهبيه للاسف
واسقاطات على دول المنطقه بما فيها الكويت
طبيعي واسقطاتها على التيارات الاسلاميه
السنيه والشيعيه الكويتيه
الثلاثه الحركه السلفيه حركه
جديده خرجت
فرضت نفسها على الساحه
ذو امتداد خارجي وعمق فكري
[موسيقى]
والتعلي اصبحت قوه جديده على الساحه بدات
تتطور وتتشكل باشكال جديده لما نصل الى
رساله الدكتوراه او الدراسه اخذت ابعاد
جديده اثرت على الحركه السلفيه العالميه
يعني ما يجري
الكويت القديمه على المجتمع
تاثير الدستور هبدا من نكمل وهذا جيد
الدستور عمل حاجه مهمه انا اذكر يعني
احد الاساتذه الاستاذ الامتحان في
الدكتوراه قال لي اذا بتكتب شيء اخر
مستقبلا اكتب عن النقطه
ال ال الدستور
اي قرض واعطى باور وقوه
لقوه اجتماعيه كانت مهمشه اسلاميه لا لا
مش مجتمعيه
مو شرط تكون مهمشه بسونيه هيكون ايضا
موضوعين مهمشه
بالواقع التاريخي اللي هم ابناء القبائل
وابناء والكويتيين من ابناء الطائفه
الشيعيه
كان في حاله التهميش طبيعيه
منها بذات الهويه الثقافيه التي تحرر
الاندماج بالدوله الحديثه
اساسا داخل الطائف
لانه مربوط بعوده الامام الغائب وانه لا
يجوز كذا وكذا يعني كانوا ابناء الكويتيين
من الشيعه يبعته اولادهم لمرشد وغيره من
المقرئين والمدرسين السنه ولا يبعثها
للحكومه
لانه في راي فقط
في العراق
من القبائل عيال القبائل
واعيان الطائفه الشيعيه تجار اهل الخير
بعد فتره قام يخرج منهم شباب اصحاب رؤى
القوميه
دينيه فبدات
اللي حدث انه الاغلبيه الحضريه
تراجع دورها
وهي وهي الحقيقه يعني اثرت حتى على الجانب
السلطه يعني هذا الشرائح الرئيسيه كانت
تعتبر من الشرائح المحافظه السياسيه
قد تكون متناقضه ولكن اثرت على التركيب
الاجتماعيه التاريخيه للبلد اللي كان فيها
السطوه والهيمنه للطبقه البرجوازيه
الاعلام السنه
الحضر السنه شوف شلون الان صار الدستور
ادى الى ان يتكون مجتمع جديد وهنا نشوف
قضيه السياسه كيف تؤثر الاجتماعيه وهذا
مهم لما نتكلم على التنميه يعني قضيه
العقد الاجتماعي السياسي
متجذر حتى في تكوين المجتمع
وتركيبته هي حركه تفاعليه تبادليه
يعني مع دخول شرائح وتفاعل اصبح في تحديدا
لكن لو تغير النظام السياسي تطور مثلا
اليه الانتخاب بالكويت راح تتغير التركيب
الاجتماعيه
كانت قائمه على عقد اجتماعي
ودفعت باتجاه كتابه الدستور انتبهت لاحقا
ان هذا الدستور هزه من مكانتها او احدث
التغيرات ماء
صح جزء كبير منها غير موقع السياسي
من معارضه بشكل تدريجي
انت عندك هالحاله من
التنوع ما بقول تشرد تنوع الطبيعي حسب
التفاعل يصير التشردمه ولكن انت امام امام
تنوع بمشاريع دينيه
والخطر فيها
اجتماعي وسياسي ان بعضها بدا يرتبط ببعض
الاجتماعي
واكثر استعدادا وتقبلا الافكار الاسلاميه
اخر وجغرافي شوفي مين لما نقول للجماعه
لان الفحيحيل والمناطق الي حواليها كان في
لحمدي والنفط والعمل بالنفط سوى عمل حاله
جديده احتكاك نقابه العمال خلق مجتمع
حضاري على فكره
متحرر اجتماعيا جزء كبير منها في ذلك
الوقت اكثر من المدينه
المدينه
في حاله
فانت عندك كلهم جهه من هذول عنده مشروع
الخاص اخضر من الاجتماعي
كان البعد السياسي انت تتكلم عن
تتكلم عن مشاريع دينيه سياسيه
وخصوصا بعد ما الكتله السلفيه
بعد الغزوه التحرير طلقت الفتاوى او يعني
اجتهدت في موضوع المشاركه السياسيه
بناخذها واحده واحده
في قضيه الدكتوره يعني هذا يجوز عشان
الحركه الفكر السلفي اساسا
هو فكر
في غايه البساطه والاشتناره والتجديد
هو العوده الى اصول الدين قران والسنه
متفاعلا مع الواقع بحقن الانسان
صار شعار السلفيه بدل ما اصلا كانت منهج
علمي متقدم عقلاني السلفيه التي يقال انه
تحارب العقلانيه هي افضل منهج
عقلاني على الساحل اسلاميه ولذلك السلفيه
النهضويه مالت منه مدرسه عصر النهضه محمد
عبده
ولذلك لما رشيد رضا
المشايخ واندمجوا في اخر ايامهم حتى مع
الحركه السلفيه
الوهابيهات لها صور يعني لما يقرا الانسان
التاريخ ويشوف التحول
يعني الان تحولت الى ان ما يسمى انها شعار
وانها محطات سلفيه اكو سلفيه منه الامام
احمد
سلفيه ابن تيميه سلفيه محمد عبد الوهاب
سلفيه الالباني
بدات تاتي السلفيات ان بدال ما نرجع الى
القران والسنه والعقل والواقع نرجع الى
تراث محطه كل واحد يختار لمحل لمن نقل لنا
الاخوان ازمتهم كانت وين
ازمتهم هم والاخوه
التيارات الشيعيه
ازمتهم في الفقه السياسي
الاخوان اندمجوا سريعا في القضيه
الديمقراطيه
وهذا احنا تكلم الان عن ازمه التيارات
اللي هي في صاله الدكتوره ونتكلم ايضا عن
واقع الوزاره مو انت في الوزاره
انا لا امثل الحكومه
في الموقف السياسي انا ممثل الحكومه
كمجتمع هنا او حافظ المجتمع على حريه انت
تروح تودي سؤال استجواب انت حر الدين انا
بقول راي الدين في هذه القضيه بشكل مؤسسي
لا يمثل السلطه ولا يمثل شده وحتى كن امين
سالتني في الحلقه اللي فاتت عن موقف
الاخرين انا اقول لك في البدايه كانت تخوف
من جانب السلطه جديد
[موسيقى]
مشهد كان له ما بعده فبعد احداث الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر التي استهدفت الولايات
المتحده في عقر دارها شنت واشنطن حروبا
شرسه في اكثر من اتجاه لم تقف المعركه
الامريكيه المفتوحه عند حدود الاعمال
الحربيه والعسكريه التي ادت الى احتلال
افغانستان وغزو العراق بل تعدتها الى تضيق
الخناق على كل صغيره وكبيره تتعلق بالعمل
الخيري الاسلامي
حتى تبرعات الخيريه حول العالم فقد كان
لها نصيب وافر من الاجراءات الامريكيه
التي طالت الجمعيات والمؤسسات الخيريه
الكويتيه المعروفه بنشاطها الكبير والفعال
وبعد سنوات من التدقيق والتحقيق برائه
ساحه العمل الخيري الكويتي من كل ما الصق
بها لكن حرب واشنطن الضروس على العمل
الخيري بكل تفرعاته
على وزارات الاوقاف في العالم الاسلامي
بدر المزيد من الجهود من اجل تعزيز
الشفافيه العمل الخيري بهدف ضمان عدم وصول
المساعدات الماليه الى منظمات تصنف
ارهابيه تجنبا لتداعيات سلبيه قد تلقي
بظلالها الثقيله على الدولي وعلاقاتها
الخارجيه
كيف استطعت كاظم وزاره الاوقاف والشؤون
الاسلاميه
التعبير عن هاجسك والقضيه التي تنشغل بها
تجديد الفكر الاسلامي
الكويتي واقع التيارات الاسلاميه في
المجتمع الكويتي
ما الذي احدثته بالظبط في هذه المساله شوف
انا اسال لا نكرر ما فات احنا نتبنينا خمس
او سته
مشاعريه مثلا يعني قلنا المشروع الثقافي
ولم نطرح فكر جبنا كل التيارات بما فيها
فكره عصر النهضه بما فيها الفكر السلفي
وكل سنه عندنا ورش عمل المؤتمر عام يناقش
هذه القضيه وكان تحت رعايه رئيس الوزراء
بفضل الشباب ان عمله افتاء متواصل وهذه
خدمه مجتمع
تليفوني 24 ساعه لا تقدم كتابه ولا شيء
الا اذا قضيه رئيسيه تقدمها مؤسسه يتم
الاجابه عليها بشكل مؤسسه
المسجد
عملنا ميثاق المسجد انه هذا المسجد للجميع
لا يجب احتكار من طرف ما في مسجد اخوان
مسجد سلام عليكم
بكل ادب وصلت
استاذن اني ازوركم عندي رايي بدي اسمع
منكم الشكل يعني انا لما اطلب استاذن
انا بقول رايي شرعي
ايام الحروب الصليبيه
شوف
السلطه
من استخدام الوزاره على الاقل في العهد
اللي انا موجود فيه اكون صادق يعني خلصنا
هنا
الى مثلا تنظيم هذه انتقل الى العمل
الخيري الخارجي العمل الخيري واجهنا
اشكاليه انه في حمار في الامل الخيري
ويقود العمل الخيري واجهات
ولجان تابعه لمن للتيارات الاسلاميه
اسوي اجتماعات صار فيها خوف
يعني كبير
طلبنا وزاره الخارجيه تكون طرفيها
تصير ازمات عندنا في بعض الحالات
في عهد الرئيس حسني مبارك رحمه الله عليه
تعزمه العراق
في القاهره
في مشاريع خيريه نعملها
في وزير الاوقاف الدكتور
خير ان شاء الله وذلك الوقت حتى كان في
شعب كويتي
رايح طابع كتب بطريقه كذا او كذا مصر
واعتقل
لهالدرجه كان
قد يكون مخالفه
تفاصيل لكن
اخذناهم كلهم الاخ خالد سلطان
فخامه الرئيس
احنا ترى هدفنا في هذا البلد هو خدمه
وبجانب التنميه
وزاره الاوقاف
الناس تبي تشتغل بدون الناس
تحددوا المشاريع وافقنا عليها تنعمل وتسلم
في احسن منها
اخر شيء هذا اسمع منك كلمه يقول حق الوزير
الاخر الوزير الاوقاف طيبين بس لانك وصلت
له ساعه
صار عندنا
واحد
دكتور علي يبي يبيها دوله طول العمر
هذا الفلوس وين تروح الدوله
احداث ثوره في كيفيه اداره الاوقاف
ولاحقا انشا وقفه الخاص وقفه
كيف كان الوضع الاوقاف وما هو التحول اللي
حدث في اداره الاوقاف
هنا في الكويت
مشكله قضيه الاوقاف مربوطه بالنقطه اللي
جبناها
الاسلاميه
اهجم 50% ابن
ليش بس استنزاف بدون لما تقول هذا باطل
وهذا باطل وهذا باطل زين وين
بديلكك
بس شغلتك محاكم تفتيش
ذكرني دكتور بس سالت الاستاذ راشد الغلوشي
قبل عشره اعوام تقريبا ماذا بعد الثوره
وتوليهم ماذا ستفعلون في المنكرات حسب
الضغط يعني من تعرض ماذا ستفعلون بشواطئ
العراه قال لا نفعل شيء سننشئ شواطئ اخرى
تنطبق عليها المواصفات التي نؤمن بها
ويؤمن بها وستكون هي منافسه للشواطئ
الاخرى بمعنى هي فكره البناء
سيترك الباطل وهو مؤمن انه باطل لكنه
سيذهب الى خلق او بناء شيء جديد تلتقي
معها هل الفكره اخو قضيه اخرى هي اللي
قادتني الى الوقت
او اكثر من قضيه
اخو قضيه
تلاحظ ان القضيه
الرئيسيه التي تفرز قوه سياسيه تشتغل
بادلجه خاصه فيها
صاحبه الحق وغيرها الباطل
وانها كلها تتكلم باسم منه باسم الله
المخيب تعرف السلطه تاخذ حقها والقوه
اللي ما ياخذ حقه المجتمع
خليني اسالك بشكل مباشر
قبل ذلك اين تذهب اموال الوقف وكيف تدر
والتحول اللي حدث في الاشياء هذه
المجتمع المجتمع
وجد في طريقين
طريق الامر معروف انها المنكر وجدت انه تم
تشويها وانها هذه قضيه عاليه متقدمه جدا
الفكر السياسي الحديث الغربي
[موسيقى]
بس اكو شيء ثاني بجوز معتقد ولم يتشوه
اللي هو الوقف
الجر المجتمع ان ينافس السلطه وينافس منه
وينافذ القوه الدينيه السياسيه لانه هو
اكثر شفافيه وتجرا
نفسه
من ماله الحر وهو واضح شنو من طاقته ووقته
ولذلك تعريف الوقف الشرعي والقانوني
والقضائي قضيب
حبس العين
واطلاق المنفعه
تاتي باصل مالي ولا عقاري وتقول انا بحط
مليون
هذا المليون بحكم قضائي يصدر من القضاء
ولا يجوز انك
تنفق من راس مالي من الوقف من الاصل تنفق
من العائد
وحسب شروط منه الناظر الذي اوقف
لذلك يقول فقهاء شرط الواقف
كنص الشارع اعطوه قدسيه
يعني اذا انت حطيت مبلغ 100 دينار ولا
مليون قلت هذا يذهب فقط للايتام او لتعليم
الصح لا يذهب الى غيرها
وقضاء وقانونا لو الناظر اللي عليه خالفه
المفروض يروح السجن
بعد مرور فتره من الزمن
يعني مثلا انت اوقفت عقار معين لحاجه
الطعام اطعام مثلا وجاء زمن ولم تعد هناك
حاجه في هذا الامر هناك حاجه اخرى لمجره
يحدث تحتاج الى اجتهاد
القرار القضاء يجتهد فيه لان هذا في
القضاء كانهم الاحوال الشخصيه الاحوال
الشخصيه يعني الاحكام الشرعيه اريد سؤالي
ما هي حجم اموال الوقت كانت اين تصرف
والتحول لحدث عليها شكرا
لا الحكومات ولا التيارات ولا الاحزاب
الناس هي تصنع حضراتك من خلال الاوقاف
اللي هو المجتمع المدني الحديث
انت لما تروح الارض ولا اكسفورد ولا
المستشفى ولا حتى الاوبرا في شيكاغو تايمز
جديده
طيب انت تبي تسوي هناك
لامليتين
للمجتمع انه يرجع يوقفوا وجدنا حركه
الايقاف جبته وقفت ما اقبلت
فلوسي يروحون في تجربه
هذه القائمه في البلدان العربيه الاسلاميه
من اعظم الدول لكن صار فيها الشام
لان لما مات بالاحكام العسكريه القاهره
تراجعت حركه يذكرني بشيء لما صارت
صار عقد مؤتمر القمه الاسلامي في جاكرتا
بعد ما تركت انا بعد الوزاره بعد الوزاره
اقروا فيه
ان التجربه الكويت تصير الكويت هي المنسق
الدولي
وان تعمم التجربه هذه كذا وقام البنك
الاسلامي للتنميه الذي هو مجلس المحافظين
فيه من وزراء الماليه في العالم الاسلامي
انشا الهيئه العالميه للوقف
علاج
كل الدول الان انطلقت يعني مثلا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا اعتقد الان
توجد حركه وقف في العالم العربي والاسلامي
توازن في المملكه السعوديه في السعوديه
المذهله في امرين اداره متقدمه وحديثه جدا
الوقف للوقف على المستوى الشعبي وحتى اكون
امين حتى على المستوى الرسمي اخر قانون
صدر انا اتمنى ان يكون لدينا في الكويت
في السعوديه تلاحظ ان فعلا دخل في هذا
المجال يعني مثل الاوقاف الشيخ سليمان
شخصيه مليار وبعدين بدا من الصفر من جديد
مكون ثوره ثروه عفوا اكثر مما كانت لديه
في السابق والبركه
ويمازح اولاده ان هذا هو مو مسؤول عن ثروه
العائله خلاص هو مسؤول عن شنو فيقول انا
غلبتكم بالاداء اللي اتفضل فيه ان اداء
افضل من الاداء العائلي
في اداء الاوقاف والعائد الحمد لله
السعوديه الان المملكه الحقيقه نموذج
متقدم جدا
كل دول الخليج بحرين الامارات اظن قطر
امارات الاوقاف
ولذلك لان اكل جانب تنسيقي لان منظمه
المؤتمر الاسلامي من خلال البنك الاسلامي
للتنميه عمل وعمل جيد ارجع للصناديق الوقت
معالم اثره طيب حتى يقبل على هذا الامر
الوقت
تنتهي تنتهي
القضاء هو المشرف
عليهن تراجع فقط للواقف بعد ما يتوفاه
الله
اذا هي ترى نوع من التنميه المستدامه
بالمال والجهد والوقت يعني
فانشئت طبعا انا ما باظلم احد يعني في
عندنا اسماء في الوضع لا نستطيع تجاوزه
مثل دخلت المحشي العثمان الامين العام
طلبناه كان وكيل مساعد في وزاره الماليه
استلمها مثلا
زملائه من الشباب
سبحان الله متميز رحمه الله عليه الاخ
محمد صقرتي انا ما انسى كلمتين
لو سويت هذا يكفيني دنيا واخره
التخصصيه
صندوق تعليمي صندوق ثقافه غير التعليمي
صندوق الصحه صندوق صندوق رعايه المعاقين
وعملنا مجلات جديده
وجبنه
الناس المتبرعين من القطاع الخاص وخلينا
معظم مجلس اداره
واجبنا من القطاع الحكومي من الوزراء
والمسؤولين السابقين ذوي الاختصاص تعال
انت وزير التعليم او تربيه سابق عندنا
مسار تعليمي نبيل مجلس اداره هنا جبت
لهم الخضره وجبت صاحب التبرع وقعتهم
يديرون صندوقهم هالشكل انت توفر للوجستك
بس خلقت مجرى ماء
اتصل فيني واحد
تسوي حكومه الظل
يطلب والله اعجبتني شو ما فاتت
لا والله صدقتك
ما فكرت فيها الشكل لكن نعم بس حكومه تضل
مو سياسيه حكومه الظل مجتمعيه شو اللي صار
الحاله الاوقاف حدثت فيها ثوره زياده
شو صارت دكتور اذا تذكر طبعا
الاوقاف الخارجيه يعني كان الاول الي واحد
يقول لي انا
بنش مدرسه مستوصف تبرعوا لي نقول لهم
الوزاره لكن
يعني بدينا نخلق ثقافه الوقف اقبل
الواقفون عليكم اقبل في رحلتنا انا اذكر
في مرحله تذكر حاله بارزه لافته الاسماء
كل هذا اللجان انشاته
كل اللي جاني الخيريه بدات تدعو الناس
للتبرع لتاسيس الاوقاف
من مساله الاوقاف
الاسلاميه انت في كل منطقه قاعد تهز اركان
عمل الطائرات الاسلاميه الدينيه
وكل مكان قاعد يعني تدخل في مناطق نفوذهم
شنو كيف تاثروا بمساله الاوقاف والتطوير
فيها في البدايه كانت تاثر سلبي وتخوف
واحنا كنا صريحين يقول احنا نستهدف انه
تذهب الى اكثر يعني
الوقف ما تروح العمل الخير اللي مش عليه
مباشره
اللي حدث هو تاثير مهم لم نكن ننتبه له
كثير من المنظويين للتيارات والحركات
الاسلاميه انسحب
وقام يشتغل على انشاء وقف ويسوي مشاريعه
وبرامجه ولقيت انا
لا انا بيشتغل
وزاره لان الوزاره وهذا اللي حدث بعدين
رده هيك مدير
اداري احنا كنا نريد ان نحرك المجتمع وانت
تستمر
الذي حدث ان كثيرين
من العاملين في الحقل الاسلامي تحوله الى
العمل المدني
وهي السلطه يجب ان تعد دائما ان المجتمع
يجب ان يحيد
السلطه انا الحين بلبس قبعات موالات وزير
سابقا
انا اقول لهم انا نيتي شيء وما بتسكن فيه
العمل المدني اذا انت اوقفت الامن
المجتمعي يرى ان لا يمثل الا التيار
السياسي والفكر الشعبي لما تنظمه وتخليه
يشتغل كثير من الاموال والعناصر والقيادات
التي تشتغل فيه وين بتروح للعمل المجتمعي
من العمل السياسي والفكري يعني حتى لو
ناخذها بالابتزاز او الموازنه السياسيه
الاصلاح هذا هدفي ان المجتمع هو الاصل
السلطه والتيارات افراز للمجتمع لا يجب ان
تهين على المجتمع الاوقاف الجعفريه تاثرت
وتاثر يعني
الاخوه الشيعه اساسا لم يكن يوقفون لانه
مرتبطين بالمرجعيه وكلاء الامام
مسلم وبالتالي
الاوقاف بسيطه وهي التي تحول من القضاء
لما يختلفون منظر او ورثه هم نضال الوقت
يختلفون ويذهب الى القضاء فكانت الارقام
ثم انشئ بعدين امانه عامه للاوقاف سريع
لان احنا بوقتنا دخلنا في الاداره
بالعناصر الاداره من الاخوه الكويتيه
انشات لاحقا وقفك الخاص وقف اسره الزمان
وقف همم لا هو اسم معين او وقف النهوض
للدراسات التاليه عاده معلن حجم همم الوقف
دكتور
للقاضي كذا كذا كذا وقف نهوض للدراسات
التنميه احنا عرضنا عن المصارف التقليديه
اللي الناس التنافس عليها
وكنا نامل ان ننشئ كليه
للابحاث والدراسات العليا وقفيه
ذهبت الى اثنين من اعز الاصدقاء
الاول والثاني في الجامعات الخاصه او
المجلس ورفضوا قالوا تطبق عليه تقدم شروط
الاخر واحنا نريد مجرد كليه ملتصقه باحدى
الكليات الخاصه بالكويت عندنا موافقه منها
من هذا الجامعه الي انتم
كليه داخلها وقفيه
صور شوفي لما ما تطور المناخ التشريعي على
مالهم يعني الؤمهم انه يقول لك ابو الهمه
الدراسات والابحاث دراسات التنميه قال
والله النظام يقول لا تروح تمشي جامعه
كامله يبقى ما في جامعه انا ما اقدر
جامعه لندن كليه
وعملنا مثلا شنو ازمه انت واقفه اسلامي
شنو ازمه الاسلام في اوروبا وامريكا
الاندماج
ليش كل الاقليات الاثنيه
والفكريه والدينيه تندمج حتى اليهود
اندمجوا ليش المسلمين
لا يجوز انك تشترط بعد ديني او اسمي لاين
نشاط تقوم في عام او مؤسسه انت موقفهم
كرسي او شيء لا احنا كنا نبي مجموعه رسائل
دكتوراه من طلبه انجليزي مسلمين من ابناء
الجيل الثاني والثالث ليكون انقطعه وعن
تاثيراتنا المشرقيه
كل واحد يقدم دراسه ما هي اسباب تحديات
الاندماج واحد اقتصاديه وواحد تربويه
وواحد قانونيا وواحد سياسيين
وهذه المنح نمولها وتدهر
موافقه من حسن حظكم انه اولويات الحكومه
اللي بريطانيه منها اندماج المسلمين
تمام
في الامتحان
احنا بس نختار الطلبه من اللجان
والموضوعات اما الجانب الاكاديمي
في مواضيع محدده سوي مشاريع مثلا مركز
دراسات
[موسيقى]
بدانا نرتبط حتى في الامل
الخيري كنا نتجنب الا في شنو الا اللي يمس
التنميه يعني مثال
عمليات العيون
تكتشف ان تقدر تسوي 500 عمليه بمبلغ تافه
لان العمليه ما تتجاوز قيمه ساندويشتين
ثلاثه وانت وربعك طالعين 40 دينار تفتح
يعني الماء الازرق
يعني تردد فيه بس يصير عندك عائله
طبعا عندنا مركز ابحث
ومركز مهم
وانتج يعني مجموعه وترجمه اعمال في غايه
الاهميه
هو هو اشكاليه يعني انت لما تدخل المجال
هذا
تكتشف اني اضرب لك مثال احنا كنا متردد
نشتغل على الاصدارات القانونيه ولا ماكو
احد يطلبها الدراسات الحديثه الان اكتشف
انها اكثر الامور شنو طلبن
اكثر الامور طلب
دراسات التجديد
تجديد الفكر الاسلامي
حتى في القضايا الفكريه والسياسيه لما
تطلع قضايا جديده
وايمانك
مثل ما قلنا الوزارات يجب ان تكون حياديه
نريد ان تكون ايضا هذه حياتي
نريد ان تكون المركز او مشاريع الوقفيه
والاهليه يجب ان تكون الحياه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر شكرا
احد المقبل دمت بخير
[موسيقى]